[Music]
[Applause]
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat up
here.
Heat.
Heat up here.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed that
flow session as much as I enjoyed making
it. If you'd like to get a hold of a set
of those LED contact po that I was using
in this video, you can use the code
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O
at checkout over at ultraoy.com. Once
again, that is Drex Factor with a zero
instead of an O. That will get you 10%
off your order. Thank you so much to
Ultra PO for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to get out and get
my flow on. Speaking of thank yous, I
owe thanks to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyera Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links I've got down in
the description of this video. And
special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel that is Becca
Beckonen. Thank you so very much for
supporting my channel, my work, and my
mission. And finally, this video and all
the videos on this channel would not
exist were it not for my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a shout out to my
fellow patrons who are listed on screen
right now. Thank you all so much for
supporting my channel, my work, and my
mission. And thank you all for watching.
If you'd like to check out more of my
flow videos, I'll include links to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up on screen. Thanks so much.
I'll see you soon and have a good one.
Peace.